it's only the one thing I do like about
what the Clippers have out there I think
if Devin Booker or KD gets it they're
going to get a good look because they
can see over their Defender so I like
the opportunity there but you got to get
the ball in
[Music]
had to call the timeout the last time
around they get it about it out of
Booker
Gordon set up on Durant hooker on the
drive comes in with the left hand
Westbrook with the block and the save as
he knocked it off of the foot of Devin
Booker trying to think Devin if you if
you don't if you're not assured of a
layup you've got to take that three I
would have taken that three something
got a foul
they do Devin should have taken that for
us I mean I know Dev is upset thinking
he got a fouls but if you had Westbrook
on you and he was kind of inviting the
three I mean he wasn't pressuring look
at that I mean that that's a step back
three for Devin and attempting a
left-handed layup in that tough
situation
man you talk about those long arms of
Westbrook they have come into play three
or four times today tapping the ball
from behind on book he's got three
blocks now on tonight so and you said it
previously say what you want about
Russell's shooting you never questioned
his hustle and tenacity
got a high basketball IQ and it's been
his place on both ends of the floor now
three straight possessions that have
made the difference in this game and
Tyler stays with him like normally he
would have taken him out
[Applause]
so I just made this a long series that's
that's basically what that is
ran with the inbound
hooker trying to get one away
left Brook will give him the clear pass
with the Clippers
stole game five here back in June of
2021.
and it'll be the Clippers
who will steal game one here
and clearly said